right we are joined by journalist Jake's
a ganar o in Paris Jake this French High
Court has ruled to suspend the ban what
immediate effect is it gonna have that's
right man the bands are immediately
overturned but only in nice and in the
town of Vilna lubo where the appeal
filed with the courts contested the band
about 30 pounds in total have
implemented bikini bands so those would
also likely be overturned if
specifically challenged in the courts so
now women who wish to wear the bikini a
head scarf or fully cover themselves in
Nice or Vilna Lubow can now return the
beaches without worrying about being
harassed by police and what were the
legal or constitutional grounds that
this court sided to suspend the bath
right well the ruling said that the
bands were a serious violation of
fundamental freedoms such as the right
to come and go freely as well as the
freedom of conscience and personal
liberty as the exact quote from the
ruling all right and we are joined now
again on the left of the screen with
Ojeda as I'm Nettie we gotta get go get
it back and screen though if not yeah i
Haena zanetti me nah they are I hate us
unless he actually invented or designed
the bikini to begin with she joins us
from Sydney Australia obviously this has
become a hot button issue all over the
world did you have any idea that your
design that you came up with about 12
years ago would take on the life of its
own like this no not at all not at all
not at all wouldn't have been been in my
dreams at that time it was a local
business in fact it started as a hobby
um you know fulfilling my local
community my friends my family um I I
had no idea it would even reach outside
of Sydney I mean and I would never have
imagined it would have reached
internationally like this and I wouldn't
have ever have imagined that people will
be talking about it the way they are now
but I'm really happy with the decisions
that's faith right now and it's just
proof to you that we have the freedom
and
these freedom of choice is not only
fulfilled by Muslim women but it should
be fulfilled by many other women um and
I'm speaking of on behalf of all women
you know and it's not women that are
Muslims or Christians or Jewish or or
Australians or English I mean it could
be anyone um we have a choice and the
choice is is that we want to be modest
so be it and so we should we should be
able to do so and enjoy the beaches as
everyone else you just used the word
modesty and a lot of people you know on
your side of this do call her job a
symbol of modesty but others say that
this is an imposition on women's rights
what do you say to that women have the
right to choose to put the val or hijab
on it's not enforced by anyone for us to
do so I mean if a certain country and
within their own culture that they think
that they have that kind of power I
don't know I'm speaking on behalf of
Australia well I'm speaking on behalf
the Middle Eastern that we are not
enforced to wear a hijab Islamically um
if people choose to enforce wearing
hijab it's a cultural thing it's not an
islamic thing sir i'm an australian and
I I was born a Muslim but I choose to
stay to be a Muslim and I chose to wear
a He shed um Jeb makes me feel complete
alright Jake I want to take this back to
you into France for a moment this has
obviously been a really big issue over
the last couple of weeks in France um
and France has a very particular
relationship to secularism what kind of
reactions do you expect now well since
the ban is still upheld in other towns
that were not even the appeal by the
league of human rights and the
collective against Islamophobia in
France we will probably see other
appeals to overturn the berkey van
everywhere else it's been a very heated
social and political debate as you said
that has divided not only the right from
the left but has also created fissures
in president principal at home socialist
party so I expect the volume will be
turned up even more in political speech
and debates about French identity and
where
when women should be allowed to wear the
hijab I hate looking at this from
Australia I mean Australia has a lot of
different cultural traditions from
France how did this whole debate going
on you know hundreds and thousands of
kilometers away from you see him for me
out so this had to strike you a bit odd
right it is it is a bit strange to
actually speak about a swimsuit us in
cities is based around happiness and
enjoy fulness and positive and health
and fitness like who would think that
we're debating about a swim well that's
a shame well I guess I'm so sorry oh no
she's back I yes I'm back so sorry I
mean who would have thought that we
we've got a world political issue about
a swimsuit um essentially he's giving
you joyfulness it's giving you happiness
it's giving you the freedom of fitness
and and and like it's supposed to be
exactly yeah I think we're gonna have to
wrap it up right right so sorry I'm so
so sorry what's quite a wretched a bit
touch-and-go thing and sometimes you
just have to pull the plug anyway Jake's
a ganar oh and I hate as a neti joining
us for that talk